hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i want to tell you
easy peasy
how to take a property deal sell it
make money without having an investor
without knowing any investors without
having an investor list
and this is something that my students
are doing
again and again and again and again and
again and again and people always come
up to me all the time
samuel how do how do i find investors
how do i sell my deal when i haven't got
an investor you don't need an investor
to begin with
and this is how you do it you find
someone
who does know investors it's like a
joint venture right here
so you find someone who's got investors
and you have a deal
now how do you find that person they
advertise themselves
because they're always posting deals
they're on social media
so when you see people that are saying
hey i just sold a deal to another
investor they're putting themselves out
there they're well-branded they're
well-marketed and you're not
and that everyone knows who they are and
that they've got loads of investors but
you haven't
what you do is instead of you trying to
be like them and trying to find them
and trying to go to the investors what
you do is you approach them and you say
hey
you've got a lot of investors
congratulations you spend a lot of time
and money in marketing
and building your brand and growing your
investors i don't do that stuff
but i am really good at finding property
deals so
how about this how about i'll bring you
a deal you sell it
and we'll go 50 50 on the profits
what kind of deals are your investors
looking for right now
let me go find those deals hello
like this this is not difficult folks
this is just called
business this is called a joint venture
between
you and a deal sourcer that means you
don't have to find the investor you
don't have to market yourself
you don't have to sell to the investor
you just focus on what you're good at
which is going finding deals
so don't find excuses find solutions if
you want to be successful in business
instead of trying to find a problem i
don't know any investors
well go and find an investor then dick
or go and find a deal sorcerer that does
have investors
tired of people making excuses because
they don't want to take action
so hope you found this video helpful
this was a short one but i've not got
much more to say
if you found it helpful let me know by
smashing the like button
also drop in the comment box as well did
you find it helpful did you not find it
helpful have you got any tips what do
you want me to do more videos on let me
know in the comment box
you might also find this video really
helpful right here that video is a
really good one
you're gonna love it check it out also
please give me a massive favor and
subscribe right here
that'd be really cool i hope to see you
at the property investors crash course
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]